مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره
[موسيقى]
انتقال ساديو ماني للنصر هل هو الانتقال
المناسب ولا لا بالتاكيد انه انتقال ساديو
مانيه هو انتقال كبير جدا وصفقه كبيره جدا
بالنسبه للنصر السعودي لانه ماني راح يزيد
من حده هجوم النصر وراح يشكل خيارات ويعطي
خيارات اضافيه لهجوم العالمي بكل صراحه
اللي حضر مباريات النصر على مدار الخمس او
ست مباريات الماضيين من وديات وبكاس الملك
سلمان للانديه الابطال لاحظ ان النصر بضيع
كثير فرص بخلق هجمات كثير بيكون قادر انه
يخلق فرص ولكن امام المرمى دائما فرص هاي
مهدوره ولحتى ما يزعلوا مني جمهور رونالدو
وبتمنى انه ما يزعلوا يعني رونالدو اضاعه
كثير فرص وكان غير فعال بالدرجه الكافيه
على مدار المباريات الوديه وحتى مباراه
الاتحاد المنستيري بكاس الملك سلمان
للانديه الابطال لذلك وجود لاعب مثل ساديو
مانيه بيوفر لك حدي اكبر وبيوفر لك فاعليه
اكبر مانيه هو مش لاعب طبعا بفاعليه صلاح
كانت ليفربول ولكن بض بسموها بالانجليزي
الليثها امام المرمى يعني بسجل اهداف
وقادر انه يحط لك اهداف كثيره ويظهر
بمواقف صعبه جدا ولحتى ندخل بعمق الموضوع
ساديو مانيه هو من افضل لاعبيه او الاجنحه
بالعالم على صعيد انه هو يتمركز خلف خطوط
المدافعين هو يكون دائما موفر لك خيار
تمرير بظهر الخط الدفاعي للخصوم هذا واحد
وهذا امر مهم جدا لانه هو عنده سرعه وعنده
مهاره وعنده حسن تمركز ولكن الميزه الاخرى
اللي بيقدم لك اياها ساديو ماني انه كمان
بيقدر يلعب كلاعب او مهاجم وهمي وبهاي
الحاله انت بتستفيد كثير لانه بحال
رونالدو يوما ما ما كان بمستواه بمباراه
معينه بحال اضطريت تبدل رونالدو لاي سبب
بحال صار في اصابه لرونالدو فبهاي الحاله
ما عندك اي مشكله بانك تحط قلب هجوم
وتلعبوا كمهاجم وهمي وتنزل غريب على الجهه
اليسرى بما انه حكينا عن غريب فعندي تخوف
شوي
غريب او عبد الرحمن غريب هو واحد من افضل
المواهب في السعوديه مؤخرا وهو افضل جناح
ربما او جناح يسار بالدوري السعودي على
الاطلاق وبراي الشخصي عبد الرحمن غريب هو
مستقبل الكره السعوديه اللي بخوفني من
التعاقد مع ساديو مانيه يؤثر على تطور
غريب وعلى وجوده على نجومته بالسعوديه
غريب لازم دائما يتحافظ عليه بشكل كبير من
النصر وبراي الشخصي ان النصر امام تحدي
كبير تحدي ليثبت انه الكلام اللي عم ينحكى
وخصوصا من رئيس الاتحاد الاوروبي شيفرين
لما قال انه تعاقدات السعوديه راح تاثر
على المنتخب وراح تاثر على المواهب
الموجوده عندهم والافضل ان يعملوا
اكاديميات قادره ان تصنعوا النجوم النصر
امام تحدي انه يرد على هاي التصريحات كيف
راح يرد عليها راح يرد عليها بانه ينجح
بتوظيف ساديو مانيه وينجح بتوظيف عبد
الرحمن غريب ويحافظ على موهبه غريب
ويستفيد منه وبنفس الوقت يحافظ على ساديو
مانيه ويستفيد منه وهذا تحدي كثير كبير
النصر التحدي الاخر اللي بيخوفني من
التعاقد مع ساديو مانيه هو انه ماني لاعب
عنده شويه ايجو يعني بحب الضوء بحب
الاهتمام الزايد فيه وبوجود رونالدو من
الصعب جدا انه يكون عندك لاعب نجم فريق
اول الا رونالدو يعني احد اسباب رحيله عن
ليفربول هو شعوره بين قوسين بعدم التقدير
في ظل وجود محمد صلاح لانه محمد صلاح كان
خاطف كل الاضواء مع النصر الان في لاعب
اخر خاطف الاضواء هو رونالدو فهل المانيه
راح ينجح انه يوفق بين الايجو تبعه وبين
حبه للاضواء ولانه يكون نجم الفريق وبين
وجود رونالدو هذا امر مهم جدا طريقه
التعامل رونالدو راح تاثر كثير على اداء
اللاعب داخل ارضيه الملعب وراح تاثر بشكل
كبير على مدى استفاده مصر من هاي الصفقه
على المستوى التسويقي التعاقد مع منامه
مهم جدا بلا شك لانه منا اسم كبير ورمز
كبير بعالم كره القدم الافريقيه ولاعب قدم
مستويات كبيره باوروبا وبالتالي اكيد اجيب
لك مبيعات قمصان راح يجيب لك متابعين اكثر
وراح اجيب لك جمهوري يروح يشوفوا بالملعب
هذا شيء اكيد ولكن مدى الاستفاده الرياضيه
هذا امر اخر هذا بحث اخر هذا مرحه اخر على
الورق صفقه مهمه جدا على الورق هي صفقه
رائعه جدا ولكن حسب التوظيف او التوظيف هو
راح يكون مقياس نجاح هاي الصفقه من عدمه
وبالنهايه النصر برايي الشخصي تعاقده مع
مهاجم اضافي هو يعني خطوه اكسترا على اللي
موجود لانه هجوم النصر ممتاز في ظل وجود
تلسكا وغريب ورونالدو لذلك النصر لازم
يركز اكثر على النواحي الدفاعيه كلنا شفنا
انه تلقى خمسه اهداف امام سلتا فيغو اربعه
اهداف امان بنفيكا نعم امام انتر ميلان
وباريس سان جيرمان تلقى هدف وحيد بس بس لا
تنسى انه كان عم يلعب بدفاعه متاخر جدا
وكان مسكر المساحات بينما لما بيلعب على
اللاعب المفتوح مثل ما عمل معسل ومع
بنفيكا الامور بتكون صعبه شوي
ايضا لاعبين بقيمه بروزوفيتش بنص الملعب
راح ياخد مساديو مانيه بشكل كبير لانه
مانيك كان معتمد بليفربول اصلا على نوعيه
لاعبين مثل بروزوفيتش
اللي كانوا يمولوه بالكرات بشكل جيد جدا
واظهرت النصر ايضا اظهره جيده جدا عنا
اليكس وعنا على الناحيه الاخرى الغنام
اثنين جيدين الى حد ما مع وجود كونان
قادرين يقدموا الاضافه لمانيه ويدعموه
هجوميه بالنهايه صفقه ممتازه مثل ما حكينا
ولكن الامور الرياضيه دائما ما بتنعرف الا
مع الوقت هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه اليوم بعد
الصافره حتى ننتقل الاسبوع المقبل تكونوا
بالف خير